what is it that makes chess960 so much
fun 90% of the games will enter the
unexplored territories it's uncharted
waters people will enjoy watching best
place in world being so creative
literally remove one there is very
little preparation if any at all and so
it's more you think at the Bourdon from
the first move it's an original position
whereas most time in normal shots now
you play theory up to say move ten move
15 sometimes even much deeper than that
the rapid time control also will lead to
more mistakes which tend to lead to more
exciting games the absolute freshness of
it is is what attracts people I think
the ability to express yourself in ways
that aren't really open to you when you
play classical chess set at this level
brings back some memories from chess
I know 20 years ago when we would see
the board and analyze from from early
stage of the game what are the special
challenges of playing chess 960 it's so
typical that you you enter the game you
know you're opening that you will play
it's based on your expectations what are
your point you can play so it's a whole
element of professional chess today and
you throw away some of the positions
they just lead to dog fights remove one
more or less there are all these weird
you know Martian landscapes on the port
bye-bye move 10 which you you don't get
back to normal you know in some case if
the pieces are so others oddly placed
that bones can be hanging all right the
very first move one thing I remember
early on when I was playing is that I
was very bad with the bishops and I
think if you're not careful it's very
easy to end up where you block your
bishops in and they don't really get
good diagonal even if we manage to
handle the opening phase well in a
totally fresh position people are
against a time pressure a lot faster and
a lot more often and that's when pieces
start flying and crazy stuff starts
happening there's also no increment so
just a time delay so I expect a lot of
time scrambles and a lot of sharp games
is chess960 the future the biggest
challenge is that this is so much
opening theory and computers making it
more and more difficult
or even for the best plans was the best
teams behind him to come up with
original ideas
personally I like it much more than
regular chess but it hasn't really
reached the big leagues it hasn't really
become very popular to the public and
top players
I believe that professional chess
players will adapt to to Fischer random
but for the normal chess fan who only
plays from the weekends it would be a
big big problem calendar is not so
tightly packed that we can't find place
for everything and then we see what what
leaves and what thrives and what doesn't
I think the main thing is you have a lot
more decisive games I don't know if it's
necessarily future but I think certainly
it's something that should be pursued
and I think it's gonna be quite
interesting to see what happens in the
mattress here let's say 50% are more
decisive and I think they will be it's
gonna prove that there is a lot of Merit
for Fischer and it's still the same same
number of squirrels the same number of
pieces but just you know reshuffling
pieces suddenly at the first rank and
the last rank so you may be gonna
inventor again